hello everybody
happy Wednesday morning welcome to
another gratitude Journal live stream
this is the third edition in this new
test series that I'm putting out the
idea here is every day you shares three
things are you grateful for to help
shift your perspective to help you
realize that you are fortunate you have
a lot to help put you in a better mood
and happiness all the research points to
being grateful as being a key component
of it and so this is a thing I do with
my team every day and I thought I'd
bring it to you guys and I'm hoping that
you will share three things you're
grateful for in the live stream as well
as in the comments below for those of
you guys watching afterwards make it a
daily habit a consistent habit because
doing it once isn't enough it's got to
be something that you do every day and
I've seen big changes in my life and
hopefully you guys see it in yours as
well
so on top of it being the daily
consistent habit because we are what we
repeatedly do the second key component
to it is that you actually feel it that
you're not just listing something off
that you're not just coming up with you
know you summarizing but you're actually
feeling because in order to have the the
impact the benefits of the gratitude you
have to put yourself in a state where
you actually feel grateful for it and
not just listening something off and so
for me today what am i grateful for and
for you guys watching live leave yours
in the in the comments cuz I want to
it's after I'm done mine I'm grateful
I'm grateful for my wife Nina every
morning she wakes up and makes me
she makes me this she makes me there's a
this gross-looking that water here and
it's just my vitamins for the day and
it's it's consistent its daily and I
appreciate it so she's always thinking
about me and it's I'm grateful that that
there's someone who has like the daily
love for me he wants me to be healthy
and keep me on my schedule I'm grateful
that it's 2016 you know if I was born 50
years earlier
none of this would be happening
none of these opportunities that I have
in front of me to be on YouTube to chat
with you guys to have an audience to
make the impact that I'm making I might
still be doing what I'm doing in a
smaller way but or maybe I'd be at some
job you know that I hate I don't know
but I'm super grateful that's 2016 in
today is today because if I was born in
a different generation I don't know that
I would be having the same impact to be
as happy as I am right now so I'm happy
it's 2016 great flows 2016 and the third
thing I'm grateful for is the courage
muscle that I've built up I have two
really difficult meetings that I have to
do tonight at 8:30 and time o'clock
tonight on the business side just this
is meanings but I don't know if I would
have taken those a number of years ago
mostly because I probably would have
been afraid afraid of addressing
conflict afraid of telling the truth I
just kind of hope that the problem goes
away instead of actually addressing it
so I'm weak 'fl that I built that
courage muscle up and you know you guys
can - it just comes from if I ever feel
like I should do something but I'm
afraid I'm afraid of being judged or
afraid of how it will appear or I'm
afraid of failing or whatever if it's
that that kind of fear that stops me
then I have to I have to go and do it
right like I'm afraid of heights I don't
want to jump out of an airplane I have
no desire to fix that fear but being
afraid to fail or being afraid of
judgment or being afraid to have a hard
conversation or being afraid to tell the
truth or being afraid to help somebody
if I feel like that deny the way to do
it
just build the muscle of pushing through
the fear so that's it that's what I got
today hopefully the audio is better
today guys yesterday I know a lot of you
were having issues with the audio or
YouTube was having issues I guess with
the audio so grateful for Nina 2016 and
grateful for the courage muscle that I
built up I want to get to you guys
leaving the chat I'm gonna get some
shout outs see what you're beat before
we can all enjoy our gratitude together
for the next five minutes until I hop on
to the next League of Legends business
Q&A with my co-host fishy cup TV what do
we got we shake up to be first one in
good morning everyone good morning Rishi
Zeno hey Patrick just in time hi Evan
welcome guys Zane oh I'm grateful for
colors because without them I think life
would be dull sorry those who are
colorblind that's an interesting one
beautiful four colors I like it I like
it then we should kept TV I'm thankful
for education and our ability to learn I
like it - I'm grateful for nature and
the beautiful Tien landscape I get to
see every day I think that's Tennessee
is it Nashville she's in Nashville
Tennessee good sometimes I don't always
get Rishi's short-form versions of stuff
it's my fault for not remembering but
beautiful Tennessee landscape I love it
I'm beautiful for having - I'm grateful
for having the absolute best
grandparents I love it that just kind of
reminds of a story it was a friend of
mine who was in Toronto and had a list
on her wall of of the number of cloudy
days in the city and she was upset about
on the number of cloudy days in the city
and and wanted to move wanted to go to
you know somewhere it was way sunnier
and we get our own cloudy days like I
don't like Toronto was anything special
in terms of number of cloudy days when
she would actually track it I felt like
that's just a wrong it's like why he
tracking negativity
and the reason why this one came up was
because well what I mentioned - is hey
you still have your grandmother here
like how about and she was close to her
grandmother at the time so how about the
the bond you have with her like why not
celebrate that why not think about her
life and how much you guys still get to
spend time together and focus on some of
the positive things in your life as
opposed to just counting counting the
negative things I think if you just keep
counting and negative things you'll have
more and more negative things continue
to happen to you anyway so that story
helped thank you for that reishi help
bring it up wait before great list today
Evan thank you dang jr. eyes in the
house
J rise hey y'all grateful to be here
with believe nation I mean you guys are
my list yesterday I'm grateful every day
for you guys it's funny how when people
first go through this exercise and he'd
be hard to come up with three things I
remember you've been doing it with Nina
and she was having a hard time coming up
with three things that she was grateful
for I don't think you man there's so
many things to be grateful for
but you really need to build the muscle
of appreciation of gratitude there's so
many things that you take for granted
and the more you do this the faster will
come the easy will be to get other
things on your list and whenever you're
in a moment of dire consequence or anger
or fear or despair at least for me
coming back to something on before
really helps because it's hard to be
angry and upset and grateful at the same
time what else we got I'm grateful for
the fact that I don't have any physical
illnesses or disorders I agreement
I agreed since it's insane how many
things could be wrong with us aren't
with us we feel for stock photography
and video sites bring creators to life
grateful for singers who move the world
and add to believe playlist wrinkle for
beautiful curvy poof's cuz her leg boobs
gr eyes J rise ID and some love Audio is
fixed I love that that's great to see
you guys I'm grateful for certain fears
because we need to survive I love it
what else we got guys what else
got much in the house I'm grateful for
coffee and chocolate for breakfast if
you are not familiar with that with much
as Channel Jen from you so much has
chocolate every morning for breakfast
and I think one day I'm gonna have to
have chocolate on the live stream I'd be
grateful for chocolate with Jen I love
it
one more minute one more minute what do
we got I'm grateful that I helped people
believe in themselves I love that Wendy
I love that I'm a hundred percent with
their I'm a hundred percent with you
there what courses you recommend for
sales training I'm doing a live stream
in one minute on League of Legends and
answering business questions if you go
to the twitch channel you'll be able to
join in on the business cue a grateful
for health having health freedom and
family that's Alex Alex Anders I love it
and that's it guys ten minutes ten
minutes goes fast so hope you guys have
an amazing day I'm feeling the love from
all of you hopefully you're starting
your day on the right foot go ahead do
something amazing today I'm gonna hop
into the league of Legends livestream I
will see you guys tomorrow morning again
for some more gratitude thank you guys
for watching you need to believe
whatever your one where it is and I'll
see you soon